truth be told the romantic bro didn't
welcome me very warmly at first it was
cool and rainy in votes book where I
kicked off my journey it was my plan to
explore Germany's favorite scenic route
in three stages on my first leg
I went from vets book by way of Luton
woke up to Taba all the way to dinkus
Phu the Romantic Road was created in
1950 it's over 400 kilometers long and
takes you through towns and countryside
in southern Germany like here through
the Talbot Valley after driving through
this beautiful valley I arrived at my
first highlight Holton book octet album
time really seems to have stood still
here you almost feel like you're back in
the Middle Ages a lot maybe old but that
doesn't mean it's dull and dusty
what do you like about it everything's
so pretty city and I enjoyed this day
dear friends come I think it's lovely
with the narrow lanes and half-timbered
houses the people's the roads
everything is very fine I like that
slightly further along the route and
dinkus booth the director of the
Romantic Road told me why it was
established in the first place
DeSilva knocks fight invade the aim was
to promote a different image of Germany
after the Second World War but we did
have to go a bit farther back in history
the oldest German scenic route was first
mentioned in 1900 as German travel route
number 1 but that very nationalistic
sounding name after the turmoil of world
war ii wasn't exactly suitable anymore
the mayors of Bhoots burg rothenburg
Augsburg and fusun actually suggested
calling the route the Romantic Road for
couples in love hoopla is unfortunately
the short form was chosen and on January
10th 1950 the Romantic Road was reopened
or refounded in Augsburg as a scenic
route the second leg was a completely
different story this time I had the
weather on my side first I made a stop
in Dona Verte
it was originally a fishing town so I
took the opportunity to meet a
knowledgeable angler who shared the
secrets of fly-fishing with me dad you'd
be so proud of me
so this is how you back cast just try it
guns lungs of the whole it back slowly
and then snap it forward going great
good this is a well sometimes people
have beginner's luck and catch a huge
fish the first time they try you just
never know but I wasn't so lucky the
last stop on my second trip was X book
I was especially impressed with a Fugazi
one of the world's oldest social housing
complexes it was established back in the
early 16th century by local merchants
jakob fuga who had it built for people
in need the major takeaway from my first
two visits to the Romantic Road there
really is no limit to what you can see
and discover